it really doesn't look like a national
crisis in the Kent sunshine but an
invisible killer has left an anxious
population happy to follow wartime rules
but for grandparents missing their
family its compliance for now across so
we have learnt it but I think
particularly when you see other kind I
think as other countries start doing
some things then people here will start
saying well hang on a minute I'm
definitely happy to comply and I think
if we all do a good job of staying safe
now staying indoors limiting our
activities and you know and shops being
continue to be closed then I think you
know we've got more likely you know more
of a chance of it of getting over it
an exclusive poll for Sky News reveals
the majority of the public generally
agree a solid majority wanting to keep
things as they are for the next few
weeks seventy-two percent saying keep
the rules on pensioners staying indoors
and fifty-one percent think primary
schools should stay shut for now
parents strongly backing school closures
over sixty five supporting measures to
keep them at home
the YouGov poll for Sky News shows that
the government is under no pressure
whatsoever immediately to lift the
lockdown but it does find high levels of
anxiety particularly amongst the young
and under 50s or experiencing financial
strain in high numbers and the over 65s
aren't seeing close members of their
family and nearly like the numbers they
were before so ministers can't be
complacent about public attitudes to the
lockdown in a time of crisis people
reassess where they put their trust the
National Health Service comes out top
with an overall trust score of 81 with
chief medical officer Chris Witte on 25
Boris Johnson still coming out positive
in the eyes of the public with a trust
score of 12 well ahead of the New Labour
leader kiss Dharma on minus 9 but TV
journalists faring badly on minus 40 as
do newspapers on minus 55 when not
arguing with the news the nation has
come to terms with boredom though simple
pleasures and pastimes as well as chores
most exciting day last week was when the
mop arrived so
yeah a lot of tidying I definitely fill
my time with more exercise I think when
I was working some unfertile at the
moment when I was working I think when
you're working in 9:00 to 5:00
particularly me I always found an excuse
not to do it they're not alone
forty-nine percent saying they're doing
more tidying and cleaning forty-six
percent more cooking 35 percent reading
and thirty percent more exercise even
though the government wants everyone out
for an hour a day just seven percent
saying they're having more sex during
the crisis it might look serene peaceful
even but with six out of ten pensioners
saying they aren't seeing their family
as much anymore
it can be easy to overlook the pain
coronaviruses causing Sam Cote Sky News